After all your struggle, at last. You've arrived before us.
I've lost track of the number of times
i've been killed so go ahead do your worst
welcome back everyone this is going to be my
full loki episode 4 video holy crap there were
so many big reveals so many moments and
so many easter eggs we have to talk about so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just leave all your favorite moments your favorite
twists from the episode in the comments careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the episode yet
because we'll be talking about everything and i
hope that you stayed after the credits because
this was the first loki episode with a genuine
post-credit scene technically it was a mid-credit
scene but we'll talk about all that there were so
many big reveals but obviously it's only episode
four there are six episodes total so this is just
the beginning i'll start at the beginning of the
episode we'll work our way through shot by shot
talking about easter eggs wtf moments and i'll
number these as we go along just to stay organized
starting with the title of the episode the nexus
event it's a reference to a couple of things
mainly to the nexus event that loki and silvi
caused on lamentus 1 that they kept referencing
throughout the episode the nexus event that would
be big enough to take down the entire tva as moby
has teased it's also meant to be a reference
to the nexus event that young sylvie apparently
caused that turned her into a variant which
we don't completely get the answers to in this
episode but i'll talk about that as we get to that
part but the opening scene is of silvi's backstory
in her version of asgard in the past we get a
sweeping shot of asgard from behind it's actually
a different view of asgard than we've seen before
i think because we visited asgard so much in the
marvel movies already the thor movies they wanted
to show you like a fresh shot of the asgard city
itself but inside the palace young sylvie is just
playing a game telling a story about a dragon
attacking asgard in a valkyrie flying in defeating
it to save the city there's a little wooden viking
ship here technically it's an asgardian ship
you may have also noticed the small toy of the
wolf here that's meant to be a representation of
fenris wolf which we saw during thor ragnarok that
was the wolf that was serving hela but in norse
mythology fenris wolf is actually the child of
loki so it's sort of like the wolf here is the
child of sylvie so to speak sort of a metaphor
for that then all of a sudden gugoon bottom raw's
red slayer character who's a hunter at this time
in history walks in to arrest her through a time
portal her designation is a 23 because she debuted
for the first time in the comics in avengers
23 which was a king the conqueror storyline
as princess renslayer she debuted as
princess friend slayer not ravonna renslayer
so i don't know if this version of renslayer was
also a princess where she originally came from
you could actually see the helmet itself inside
her trophy case with all the other trophies from
their cases so the idea is that a long time ago
about a thousand years ago or so because silvie's
about the same age as our version of loki and
he's just a little over a thousand years old
she was just a normal hunter a little bit lower on
the chain and she's worked her way up to the level
of judge at this point in history it seems like
next week in episode 5 is when we get the full
reveal on her backstory ren slayer's backstory
then they haul her to the tva and use a time reset
device to wipe the area wipe her timeline erasing
it from existence so even if silvia wanted to in
present day she couldn't go back to where she
came from but they haul young sylvie through to
the processing area that we saw in episode one
there's a different female desk worker meaning
the casey probably hasn't started working here
yet or he hasn't been promoted to that position
the person that she sees them manhandle who's
crying out for help here with that giant mustache
you may have recognized was the same tva agent
who was monitoring the desk station here when
sylvie set off all those time reset device bombs
creating all those different branch timelines
so if he seemed familiar that's why it's meant to
be the same person so which is meant to reinforce
the idea that all these tva agents are variants
themselves like they stole him from somewhere
in history and then like he still has this big
mustache but he has a vastly different haircut
it seems like they've altered his personality
just a little bit and he's sitting here
monitoring this desk here watching this station
then she goes through the same processing system
that loki went through during episode one she
sees the exact same processing clerk who asked
loki to sign his name to everything he'd ever
said she goes through the booth to verify that
she's not a robot or an android as some form
of artificial life then when ren slayer tries
to haul her before a judge for sentencing she
stomps on her foot steals her time pad device
opens a portal to escape sort of confirming my
theory that at some point she would have escaped
as a child and this is how she did it so she had
a time pad in the way that adult sylvie explains
it later to loki when they're still on lamentis
one is that it took her a while like jumping
around a lot before she figured out the trick
of hiding in apocalypse events and even though
they've been kind of vague about what it takes to
create nexus events like what is it about sylvie
that creates nexus event she said that whatever
she was whatever was different about her was so
strong that everywhere she went every time she
interacted with someone it created a new nexus
event i think we'll learn more about that during
episode five and episode six like what is it about
her that's so different because even at the end of
the episode renslayer refuses to tell her what the
nexus event was that turned her into a variant but
then we jumped to renslayer in present day who's
sort of remembering the events like it's implied
that she's remembering sylvie's past because she
does tell her later in the episode oh i remember
you she goes into the room where the timekeepers
are we see their silhouettes she seems really
pensive like she's afraid about what's going
to happen when she talks to them the podium that
they're on seems very similar to the version of
the comic book podium that they sit on like they
are trying to make them look at least like the
comic book versions even if the mcu versions are
meant to be fake like they're robots in the comics
they're actually real the time keepers are actual
physical organic beings but here's the thing with
the big reveal about them during the episode at
least at this moment it's not really clear what
ren slayer knows and what she doesn't know because
the way they play her during the episode they
want you to think that she's been complicit this
whole time like she's actually known the secret
and she's been lying to everyone getting rid of
people right and left when they start to get close
to uncovering the secret but because of the twist
of what happens with loki in the post-credits
scene revealed that he wasn't really killed by
her it kind of throws into question how evil she
really might be like is this all a misdirect and
she's actually still a good character it's just
that for most of the episode the way they play
her they want you to think that she's really bad
but that also feels like it could be another
misdirect so it's not totally clear whether
or not she understands that the time keepers
themselves are robots and fake i think this
also gets into the idea that she kind of wanted
sylvie to kill her at the end of the episode
right now though it just seems like she's afraid
to face them and they obviously don't tell you
what it is that they told her there's just a time
jump to where she comes out and starts talking to
mobius and he starts grilling her on what's
going on and obviously a lot of this was all
misdirect like she kept trying to avoid answering
any of mobis's questions directly giving away any
real information about the time keepers making
it seem like she was hiding things on purpose
then back on lament one we check back in with loki
and sylvie who are kind of resigned to their fate
in the apocalypse like sylvie actually genuinely
feels like she's going to die like i live during
apocalypses and i'm gonna die during an apocalypse
all the special effects for this part of the
episode are actually pretty fantastic even though
it goes by pretty quickly just the wide long
shot of the planets colliding and while that's
happening they start playing a really sad sounding
version of the loki theme song sort of like a
lamentation their own lamentous one silly explains
that the universe wants to break free manifesting
chaos like her being born the goddess of mischief
instead of being born a man even though it's still
not clear what it is about her that created the
nexus event but the whole idea of the universe
wanting to break free is a big metaphor for the
sacred timeline and whoever's controlling the time
keepers the tva in general breaking free from this
system that is mobius has them turn up the dials
on other detection equipment in the tva to sort of
find the needle in the nexus haystack loki and
sylvie have this genuine moment and i love how
the idea of them just having this tender moment
together is so abnormal for loki's that it creates
an atomic level nexus event that they sort of
continue to reference throughout the rest of the
episode like the way mobius talks about it later
they're in love like they have some relationship
that's slowly kind of building between the two of
them like they might be falling in love with each
other and that's such a weird thing that it's
going to completely tear down the entire tva
it's certainly a spicy one i mean it wouldn't
be loki if it weren't something really crazy
like this silvie references something during
their conversation that mobius said in episode
1 when he claimed loki always seemed destined
to lose like are you destined to lose loki says
even though they do lose painfully sometimes they
don't die they survive that's a reference to all
the times he faked his own death in the mcu which
he himself references later in the episode but the
statement is also meant to foreshadow the events
of the post-credits scene where loki wakes up to
find the multiple other loki variants telling
him that he's got to come with them or he will
die soon like there are also a bunch of other loki
variants like sylvie who escaped then because of
that giant nexus event that they caused by sort
of coming together mobius hauls them in i love
loki complaining that they're demeaning him by not
treating him like a greater threat because sylvie
has way more guards on her but mobius takes him
to a time theater throws them through a different
red colored portal that he calls a time cell like
it's their version of throwing a prisoner in an
isolation cell which is basically like a time loop
for something really terrible to happen to them so
it really is a effective form of torture they said
that the whole twist with loki revealing the truth
to him the tva has been lying to you as they haul
him in setting up the big payoff at the end of the
episode that loki was right this whole time mobius
even acknowledges it even since the beginning of
episode 1 when he first called him in saying the
timekeepers the tva just completely ridiculous a
complete farce and turns out he was right but
the way they explained this it is actually an
event from the regular 616 sloki's past before r
loki became a variant so it's before the events
of the previous marvel movies at some point like
some point in his history when he was much younger
jamie alexander comes back as sif and i believe
she's also supposed to come back during thor
love and thunder or at least it seemed like she
was coming back the way she was posting on her
instagram but basically the situation here is that
at some point in their history loki played a trick
on her and cut her hair and she just got really
pissed off at him so she knees him in the balls
but because it's a time loop she needs him in the
balls continuously over and over again the whole
thing with her telling him you're always going to
be alone you're going to die alone it just meant
to set up the twist at the end of the episode when
it kind of seemed like he was almost ready to kiss
sylvie he also kind of admits later when he's in
the loop trying to break the loop to sif saying
okay i do this because i'm a narcissist i'm afraid
of being alone i crave attention mobius asks
later do you really want to die alone telling him
you can be anybody you want to be you can even be
a good person which is another reference to the
616 loki fully redeeming himself like you can
eventually become a hero character so this is them
highlighting his redemption arc on the series here
then the way they play all these mobius renslayer
scenes early on i think the reason why she doesn't
want him interrogating her is because she knows
about silvie's enchantment powers and doesn't
want him to learn about all the variants the
secret that everyone at the tva is a variant
so i think by this point of the episode it's
pretty clear that she does know about that secret
they also set up hunter b15 storyline helping
sylvie out because as she explains later when
sylvie enchanted her she also saw a memory from
wherever it was she came from we didn't see what
the memory was but she saw one bringing her around
fully to team loki or team sylvie however you want
to think about it but the cool easter egg here too
is that when she's talking to mobius he says they
process variants of cree titans who are people
from thanos's home planet the people of titan who
themselves are eternals who we're gonna see during
the eternals movie later this year it's just that
people from titan are different branch of eternals
but he also says that they've hauled in vampires
which is huge because it's meant to foreshadow and
sort of tease the blade movie with mahershala ali
so vampires are now canon in the mcu if you didn't
think they were before it's just that as far as we
know we haven't seen any vampires on screen it'll
be funny to see how they sort of work that in the
background like we've been amongst you this whole
time you just didn't realize till now like the
way they explained that the eternals characters
have been on planet earth for thousands of years
but we didn't know about them till present day
he also references loki and sylvie's demigods
providing some more context for the asgardian
gods like thor odin hela who also gets a bit
of a name drop at the end of the episode when
loki's like am i in hel the h-e-l version of
hell the asgardian hel sort of where they fit in
the cosmic pantheon of gods of the mcu not capital
g gods lowercase g gods kind of like ego of the
living planet called himself a god with a little g
that'll be really important for the gore the
godbutcher storyline in thor love and thunder
but gore will be going around killing all the
gods of the marvel universe during that movie
the way they paced out the episode though
hunter b-15 and mobius both kind of figure
out the secret or come to the realization of all
the variants inside the tva about the same time
mobius seems like he's a little more skeptical
at first though hunter b15 seems like she's
dead set like she immediately goes to talk to
sylvie like you come with me we're going to
go to that apocalypse event so you can reveal
what's going on and show me that memory again
they sort of tease out more of the loki's
sylvie arc when mobius lies to him saying
that sylvie was erased and it almost seems
like loki's heart bursts inside his chest
like he almost has a similar reaction to when
he learned about what happened with his mother
his whole lie about sylvie that he tried to give
mobis was also kind of funny too oh she came to me
a long time ago on asgard and i've been pulling
the strings this whole time although he does
talk about them hatching a plan a long time ago
even though it's a lie he talks about it coming
to fruition something really big happening really
soon that is also meant to foreshadow the big wtf
ending of the episode even though in this moment
he's actually lying about something else it's kind
of fun to watch him and mobius try to outlie each
other like they're playing four-dimensional chess
with the lies trying to get each other to reveal
the truth but eventually mobius does goad loki
into snapping and telling him the truth you're all
variants the time keepers have been lying to you
they didn't create you they stole you from where
you came from you were kidnapped owen wilson also
has a really great performance during this scene
too because you can tell that he's kind of shook
by what loki tells him he kind of believes
it but he doesn't completely give it away
like he's kind of thinking about this lost 90s jet
ski pass that he might have buried deep inside him
which he then does reference later in the episode
you know where i go if i could go anywhere
i would go back to where you took me from maybe i
even had a jet ski then then while this is going
on you see that scene play out between sylvie
and hunter b-15 the whole idea with it raining
here on them is that it's sort of a metaphor for
it washing away the lies of the tva as she comes
back into her memory still be sort of unlocks
them again for her the funny connection here is
because jonathan majors who's playing kane the
conqueror in the mcu was in lovecraft country
but wumi masaku was also in lovecraft country as
a different character so just a funny coincidental
connection between her b-15 and king the conqueror
in a completely different project so post all the
jokes about this actually being the events of
her life before the tva took her mobius has
another big conversation with ravona renslayer
and i think at this point she's such a bad liar
it's so obvious the lies that she's telling him
that mobius is just kind of nodding his head just
thinking oh my god this is all bullcrap as she
sort of hangs silvie's sword on her trophy case
he swipes her time pad with the footage of c20
later as he's watching it he sees the footage of
her debrief where she's basically explaining what
she meant when she said it's real it's real as
he was asking earlier in the episode what was she
talking about she was just referencing the events
of her memories like it was real i really did live
on earth and it actually lists her birth date on
the time pad here she was born in 1979 the date
here march 15th 2015 is supposed to be the day
that episode 3 took place the events of her death
although because of what happened with loki being
sent to this other post-apocalyptic world you do
kind of wonder when people get melted are they
really getting melted are they just getting sent
somewhere else but he does see that rent slayer
is the person who stopped the debrief before c20
could continue explaining what sylvie showed her
about the truth of them all being variants like
i said it was pretty clear earlier in the episode
that renslayer knew about the secret of all
the tva agents and the people that worked there
being variants mobius finally goes full team loki
then brings him back but finds that renslayer is
waiting for him with a team of hunters they pay
off that jet ski reference as she seemingly has
him erased like i said still big question
about what's really happening here if loki
survived the events of this but the whole thing
with mobius is i feel like they kill him off so
quickly and so nonchalantly that we will see him
again as loki said earlier in the episode during
their conversation he told him you're on a loop
just like everyone else and his name mobius is
a scientific reference to this idea of a single
sighted surface that just loops around on itself
like the name mobius implies time loop as in we'll
see mobius again sometime before the end of the
series because it's a time travel series there's
so many ways that you can bring that character
back so this is probably not the last time we'll
see this character also i think the loki twist
in the post-credits scene sort of helps support
that idea like if we're seeing loki again after
he got disintegrated then clearly we're probably
also going to see mobius again at some point too
but then renslayer takes them up in the elevator
to see the timekeepers arguably to have them
killed erased in front of the time keepers in the
way they played this scene between renslayer and
sylvie like tell me what was the nexus event
why was the reason that you erased my timeline
what was so terrible that i did when she says i
don't remember and has that evil smile on her face
they want to make it feel like she has zero
compassion for her like she doesn't care about
her at all like it's another version of the thanos
meme you took everything from me but in actuality
she did just say that i do remember you she's
just saying that she didn't remember what the
nexus event was that could also be a lie as well
the architecture where the timekeepers are the
special room where their robots exist seems
kind of like this crazy m.c escher painting
but then is there about to be a raise hunter b-15
rushes in to save them takes their callers off and
reveals that she even went back to renslayer's
office to steal sylvie's sword back for her
they knock her out during the fight so she's still
alive she'll be back during episode 5 but for
the rest of the episode she's out for the count
the middle time keeper goes full doctor strange
sylvie we've come to bargain as she then cuts its
head off promptly revealing the lie that they're
robots and the even stranger thing about this
too is that the other two timekeeper robots start
laughing uncontrollably like whoever's behind this
is laughing uncontrollably just in general i'm
getting this really strong miss minutes vibe here
too like obviously there's a lot of theories that
there's another version of loki that's controlling
all this like post all your agatha harkness memes
it was loki all along but if you think about the
idea that miss minutes is a digital ai and they
were sort of joking about how she had a physical
form like she could jump around and walk around
in three-dimensional space she wasn't bound to the
screens as a character she seems so saccharine so
overly sweet that it seems like it's hiding
something sinister behind her so still just
a couple theories out there about who's really
behind this i know people are also wondering if
king the conqueror is connected to this because
ravona renslayer is so connected to him in the
comics early guesses that by the end of episode
5 we'll have enough clues and evidence to really
narrow down the list of suspects for who the
actual main villain of the series is so everybody
let me know in the comments who you think is
actually behind the robot timekeepers like who is
actually behind all this but just as it seems as
loki is about to kiss sylvie and explain their
epic level nexus event that mobius was talking
about earlier that could bring down the tba ren
slayer seemingly erases him with her wand and i
don't think they planned it this way but it looks
a lot like the scene that vision went out on hex
vision went out on at the end of the Wandavision
finale where he's basically saying goodbye my love
but we will meet again someday they play it like
it's a huge wtf twist like wait a minute did they
just kill loki isn't he supposed to be the main
character of the show did they go full ned stark
game of thrones on us but clearly that's not true
because in the post-credits scene we see that
he wakes up on that apocalyptic version of earth
silvie doesn't know this though but then demands
that renslayer tell her the whole truth so it
does sound like we'll find out all of renslayer's
backstory how she's connected to all this during
episode 5 next week so you wanted to wait that
long to get all these answers the new song that
plays over the credits is if you love me by patti
labelle and i think the song is mostly meant to be
a metaphor for loki and sylvie's relationship then
in the actual post-credits scene loki wakes up on
the apocalypse version of earth but he asks
if it's hel like the asgardian hel am i dead
that's the place where odin trapped hela in
the mcu in that prison for thousands of years
and in the comics it's the place where she rules
over it's one of the realms where asgardians go
after they die if they don't go to valhalla like
in norse mythology it's kind of like their version
of the christian hell in afterlife of sorts odin
for instance right now who just died during thor
ragnarok ascended to valhalla which is kind of
like another dimension another state of existence
hel is kind of the same for asgardians you could
travel there as a person like even if you're alive
you can still travel there and then come back from
death so to speak like you would come back from
another dimension but then we hear richard grant's
voice who's unmistakable even if you didn't know
who he was playing you probably recognized his
voice instantly answering loki saying that no
you're not dead but you will be dead soon if you
don't come with us and reveals that he's playing
classic loki like we all thought that he was last
year he's wearing the og loki comic book costume
which kind of looks like the cosplay version
of loki from his first appearance in journey
into mystery number 85 jack kirby thor and loki
stories there's a version of kid loki played by
jack veal which we also heard about last year that
was rumored for a long time his costume is comic
book accurate he originally debuted in thor 6-1-7
there's another version of loki wielding a version
of mjolnir that's what this hammer's supposed
to be i believe the credits only list him as
the boastful or the prideful version of loki he's
played by diobia opare i'm probably mispronouncing
his name but then this is so awesome there is
a crocodile version of loki crocodile loki or
alligator loki however you want to think about
him with a little loki crown of horns on his head
i couldn't find any specific comic book references
to alligator loki but i think this is meant to be
like their version of the spider pig twist
from spider-man into the spider-verse like
gimme spider-pig but make it loki if you look
in the background you can clearly see the runes
of the avengers tower and what seems like the
new york city skyline but this is just this
post-apocalyptic place it seems like it's planet
earth but they're not really clear about that yet
this also might be where all the president
loki scenes happen because there's this
distinct post-apocalyptic vibe around his little
throne room and his minions here in the trailers
so it just seems like there are a lot of loki
variant refugees living out in this place
but if you spotted any big easter eggs during the
episode that i didn't talk about during the video
just write them below in the comments i feel like
i'm gonna have to watch the episode a couple more
times to catch everything probably my favorite
episode so far i feel like this episode blows
all the other episodes out of the water i've got
a couple bonus videos planned obviously i'll talk
more about that post credit scene the timekeepers
reveal and i'll do a loki episode 4 trailer video
so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of those
everyone click here for all my other loki episode
videos and click here for my non-spoilery black
widow movie review thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!